معنا اذا من مدينه نورداك في غازي عنتاب
مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد العظيم محمد
عبد العظيم مرحبا بك ماذا عن الوضع حيث
انت
نعم
الوضع في مدينه نورداغ هو
عمليات الانقاذ متواصله وجهود التي تقوم
بها فرق الانقاذ المتواجده في المدينه منذ
سته ايام متواصله بل
نشهد كثافه في عمليات البحث والتنقيب بين
الانقاض وعدد الاليات ازدادت وعدد الفرق
ازدادت هذا اليوم في مدينه نورداغوا قبل
تقريبا ساعتين من الان اخرجت فرق الانقاذ
التابعه لاها لمؤسسه الاغاثه التركيه
خمسه اشخاص من تحت الانقاذ بعد قضائهم 130
ساعه تحت الانقاض هي عباره عن عائله من
اب والام وثلاثه اطفال نحن نريد ان نعطيكم
صوره اوضح للدمار والخراب في مدينه نورداغ
من خلال كاميرا الجزيره الطائره التي
نحاول ان نشاهد فيها حجم الدمار الهائل
الذي حل بهذه المدينه
وكيف تعمل فرق الانقاذ وكيف تعمل فراق
المساعدات والخيم التي نصبت في مدينه
نورداغ هذه المدينه التي
تعداد سكانها ما يقرب من خمسين الف مواطن
اصبح 80% منهم بلا سكن تركوا منازلهم
واصبحوا خارج هذه
المنازل هذا الذي تشاهدونه في الصوره هو
مجمع سكني
انهار واقبل اكثر
لا يوجد كلهم توجهوا اما الى الخيام اما
الى الطرقات واما الى مناطق اخرى خارج
مدينه بلده نورداغ وكل البلدات المجاوره
لبلده نورداغيه متضرره مثل هذا الضرر الذي
نشاهده هذه هذه المنطقه التي نشاهدها هي
المنطقه التي تم اخراج خمس اشخاص كما قلت
هذا اليوم ام واب وثلاثه اطفال
خرجوا احياء من تحت هذه الانقاض بعد 130
ساعه قضوها تحت هذه الانقاض واخبرنا مدير
اداره
الاغاثه التركيه اياها ان هؤلاء الذين
خرجوا كانوا بصحه جيده وما نقلهم بسيارات
الاسعاف الى مناطق
قريبه من لتقيم فيها
المستشفيات ميدانيه اقيمت على اطراف
المدينه نلاحظ هنا في الصوره هو المخيمات
التي نصبت في المناطق الخاليه داخل
المدينه والتي بعيده ليست قريبه
على الاحياء السكنيه ولا العمارات السكنيه
هذه الخيم نصبتها مؤسسه اداره الطوارئ
والكوارث التركيه افاد
ويتجمع يتواجد فيها الاهالي الذين يرفضون
مغادره المدينه والذين لا يزال لديهم
عالقنا تحت الانقاض ونحن نتحدث عن اليوم
السادس
لهذا الزلزال
وفرص بقاء ليست اصبحت ضئيله وبالتالي
اليوم ربما يتم اخراج عدد اكبر من الجثث
من داخل هذه
الانقاب في المشهد الذي في الصوره نشاهد
ايضا خيم اقامتها
قطر الخيريه وكما نعلم ان فرق الانقاذ
القطريه
تتواجد في مدينه نورداغ بكثافه وهي على
شكل قوات لخويا القطريه والقوات من وزاره
الدفاع القطريه وقطر الخيريه ايضا تتواجد
في هذا المكان وتقدم المساعدات والعون الى
اهالي مدينه نورداغ وتقيم لهم خيم في هذا
المكان وفي اطراف مدينه نورداغ على مسافه
نحو خمسه كيلو متر من مدينه نور دار في
هذه الصوره التي تشاهدون هذه ملابس جبل من
الملابس
احضرت من قبل التبرعات من بقيه المدن
التركيه
افراد تبرعوا بملابسهم الخاصه وتم ايصالها
الى هذا المكان وهذا المشهد نشاهده في كل
المدن والبلدات والكبيره التي تعرضت الى
دمار نشاهد المساعدات الفرديه والطوعيه من
الاهالي فضلا عن المساعدات التي تقدمها
الجمعيات الرسميه والجمعيات الاهليه داخل
تركيا بالاضافه الى المساعدات الدوليه
التي تصل الى
تركيا من مختلف الدول والرئيس التركي تحدث
عن ان 70 دوله قدمت مساعدات وطلبه ارسال
فرق انقاذ الى مدينه نور دار هذا هو
المجمع السكني الذي
انهار بالكامل لم تبقى فيه الا هذه
العماره التي تشاهدونها في الصوره وهي ايه
للسقوط فرق الانقاذ حذرتنا من الاقتراب من
هذه العماره السكنيه لانهم يتوقعون انه
اذا ما حصلت اي هزار ارتداديه في مدينه
هذه العماره واحده من عمارات كثر ربما
تسقط في ايه لحظه اذا ما حصلت اي هزه
ارتداديه داخل هذه المدينه ولذلك مثلا
نشاهد هؤلاء الذين يسكنون بعيدا عن
العمارات السكنيه
لان
الفرق الانقاذ التركيه وخصوصا اداره
الكوارث والطوارئ التركيه تمنع الاهالي من
الاقتراب من العمارات السكنيه العاليه
وتحذرهم لانها تتوقع ان تسقط هذه العمارات
في ايه لحظه خصوصا اذا ما حصلت تهزات
ارتداديه ونحن قبل تقريبا ساعتين من الان
وكنا نستعد للظهور على الهواء مباشره حصلت
هزه ارتداديه شعر بها الجميع ونحن
شعرنا بها تحركت الارض تحتنا لكن الحمد
لله لم يحصل لم تكن كبيره ويبدو انها
اقل من خمسه درجات وبالتالي الشعور بها
كان واضحا ولكن لم يحدث اي ضرر في هذه
المدينه ونحن نعرف ان هناك ما يقرب من
الفيها ارتداديه قد حصلت خلال الايام
الماضيه بعد
زلزال كهرمان مرعش المدمر الذي حصل قبل
سته ايام على كل من المفيد جدا ان نشاهد
المنطقه كما نشاهدها الان عبر هذه
الكاميرا عبر الطائره لان يعني معظم
الناجين عبد العظيم في الايام الماضيه في
تلك المناطق وربما انتم ايضا تشاطرون هذا
الراي كانوا يقولون ان حجم الدمار في تلك
الم
يفوق بكثير عندما تراه العين المجرده يفوق
بكثير ما يمكن للكاميرا ان تلتقيته ربما
هذه الصوره تقربنا اكثر من حجم ما حدث
اريد ان اعود بك عبد العظيم الى موضوع
انتشال خمسه اشخاص من عائله واحده على قيد
الحياه اليوم بعد 130 ساعه من بقائهم تحت
الانقاض هذا الامر كيف ينعكس عندما يحدث
في هذه المرحله كيف ينعكس على الاهالي
الذين ما زالوا هناك في تلك المناطق
ينتظرون ان يعني يتم انتشار الاقاربهم من
تحت الانقاض وايضا كيف ينعكس على فرق
الانقاذ التي تعمل دون كلل
نعم بالتاكيد ال سي ونحن نتحدث عن فرق
الانقاذ والاهالي الذين نشاهدهم في خصوصا
وانا منذ يومين في مدينه نورداغ كان
الشعور يوم امس وصباح هذا اليوم ان
الاعمال قد اصبحت شبه معدومه
لاخراج ناجين لكن خروج هؤلاء الخمسه اشخاص
اصاب الكثير نحن عندما وصلنا الى المكان
وكان للتو قد تم اخراج هؤلاء الخمسه اشخاص
فريق الانقاذ التابع لمؤسسه الاغاثه
التركيه اياها كانوا فرحين جدا وكانوا
يتحدثون مع الجميع اننا اخرجنا خمسه اشخاص
بعد 130 ساعه
والاهالي كانوا موجودين في مكان قريب
وكانوا يتحدثون الى الفريق الانقاذ اياها
ويتحدثون ان هناك لا يزال عالقين لدينا في
تلك الاماكن اي ارتفعت معنوياتهم واصبح
لديهم امل كل التحليلات التي كانت تخرج
خلال الايام الماضيه كانت هذه التحليلات
تتحدث عن ان اربعه ايام
يستطيع المراه ان يبقى فيها تحت الانقاض
خصوصا انه بلا ماء وبلا غذاء وتحت ظروف
قاسيه وحتى التنفس صعب جدا لكن اليوم
لازلنا حتى الان نسمع اخبار تاتينا من
مختلف المناطق ان هناك ناجين تم اخراجهم
فتاه عشرينيه اخرجوها قبل قليل من تحت
الانقاض في احد المناطق المدمره
والاصبح هناك امل ان هذه التحليلات ليست
صحيحه ليست واقعيه ان ان الذين تحت
الانقاظ
يقاومون هذه الظروف الصعبه
وهناك ربما نعم اشكرك سنكتفي بهذا القدر
مدير مكتب الجزيره في تركيا عبد العظيم
محمد من مدينه نوردا غ في غازي عنتاب